les plaisirs oies se ressaisit son
fédérale 3 après avoir perdu contre
meaux le 23 octobre
les bleu et jaune ont fait qu'une
bouchée de leurs voisins yves binois
houille à l'occasion de la 6e journée du
championnat
le score est sans appel 39 à 5 avec
notamment quatre essais marqués en
première période ce qui a fonctionné en
première mi temps tout au moins c'est
de la patience du collectif un bon
collectif
une bonne application de ce qu'on met en
place je pense qu'on s'est bien retrouvé
devant en première mi temps même si
encore beaucoup de choses à régler
notamment sur la défense où on a un peu
levé le pied en deuxième mi temps
ce dimanche les plaisirs ondes une
nouvelle fois faire face à une cascade
de blessés deux joueurs majeurs ont dû
déclarer forfait pour la rencontre dont
le capitaine fonds soit le vilain je
crois que c'est le propre de toutes les
équipes avec eux mais en jouant joue
avec les moyens qu'on a au moment et
puis après la roue tourner j'espère que
on aura
on arrêtera d'avoir une série noire
parce que depuis le début de la saison
on passe pas un match ça me laissait
deux joueurs minimum par dix matches ça
fait beaucoup
le nombre de blessés dans l'effectif ne
se ressent pas sur le plan comptable
avec cette victoire les plaisirs oies
sont deuxièmes du classement à 8 points
du premier et surgissent et peuvent
toujours espérer monter cette saison
à la vue des équipes qu'on a rencontrés
jusqu'à maintenant quand je pense qu'il
y en a trois qui se dégage c'est ris
orangis mots et nous mêmes et
certainement après ou evreux qui
viendront viendront nous nous gratter un
peu derrière le plaisir rugby club se
déplacera le 13 novembre sur le terrain
de caen la lanterne rouge du championnat
de fédérale 3
[Applaudissements]